bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs avec stéphane laborde bonjour
stéphane bon jouer loi c'est très chaud
c'est très chaud là on vient de voir la
partie donc cris tchouk kasparov
quand vous invite à revoir puisqu'il est
totalement extraordinaire une partie
d'en faire une partie vraiment
surprenante incroyable dont ils ont fait
deux matches nuls deux matches nuls et
donc y aura des plis se départagent ce
soir entre kasparov et great choc alors
là nous allons maintenant voir la
deuxième demi finale c'est le match
judit polgar contre livni bas relief et
judith colliard part avec un handicap
puisqu'elle a perdu la première partie
avec les pièces blanches avec les pièces
blanches et que donc bas relief
maintenant aller blanc et donc in une
nul lui suffit il va pas vraiment pas
prendre trop de risques et il va tenter
d'assurer aux besoins de croiser bas
relief stéphane oui il avait l'air très
attentifs et très très curieux de la de
comment s'était déroulée la partie entre
kasparov écrit tubes des pendus à ses
lèvres quand tu lui expliquer ce qui
s'était passé
oui tout à fait très très intéressé mais
surtout il je crois que le truc le plus
important c'est qu'il avait l'air
vraiment détendus
oui il avait l'air assez serein
effectivement souriant détendu et il a
l'air d'être à très confiant pour ça ce
match revanche c'est sur c'est sûr
yevgeny bas relief est confiant il est
tranquille il connaît ses capacités
il sait qu'il joue très bien très solide
et donc il ne perd presque jamais c'est
donc le favori de ce match après le
résultat de la première partie cependant
judith a des ressources et leur un
répertoire d'ouvertures qui lui permet
de jouer départ des positions très
incisive y compris avec les pièces
noires oui effectivement
jouer notamment six bars y ajouter 4
elle peut jouer une estonienne et varié
le jeu toujours des 4 mai notamment elle
avait joué une belle est indienne
d'ailleurs dans les premières rondes si
je me rappelle bien oui sans doute alors
je veux plus de quatre parties je suis
peu parler d'elle à déjouer ces 5
oui oui c'était contre joël lautier
c'était dans l'élite se départagent
voilà elle a joué une très belle est
indienne c'était une attaque baïonnettes
et on pourrait bien revoir ça ici dans
cette partie d'un relief contre paul
guerre alors que beaucoup de
journalistes sont là tous les
journalistes sont très très chaud donc
ils vont venir comme d'habitude il
tourne autour de la scène et voilà judit
polgar qui arrivait avec son sac à dos
sous les applaudissements j'avais très
dur vous lui dites jeudi à risque d'être
très très dur on voit pas trop varié
fils est très solide c'est sûr
d'ailleurs il arrive yevgeny bas relief
le voilà est ce qu'ils avaient perdu des
partis dans la qualification contre
kasparov stéphane il avait perdu contre
kasparov
ça y est ils s'installent gif khenin bas
relief contre judit polgar donc on vous
rappelle que si vous avez des remarques
à faire sur le chat est violent
faites-le nous répondrons aux questions
les plus généralistes on peut pas
répondre aux variantes précise puisque
il ya un petit décalage entre le temps
de la question et de la réponse donc
poser vos questions par exemple si vous
vouler savoir on savoir plus sur bas
relief sur j'ai dit ou sur la position
en général mais sans variante puisque
c'est un peu compliqué techniquement
voilà nous avons évoqué ni bas relief
très concentré il sait qu'il doit faire
nul qui lui suffit de faire nul pour se
qualifier en finale de cette coupe du
monde d'échecs et donc il va tout faire
pour en un peu judit polgar en face elle
aussi connaît les enjeux stéphane elle
sait qu'elle est obligée de gagner les
origines gainey avec les noirs ce qui
est très très difficile
alors que l'arbitré met en vente la
pendule ses saillies nous allons tout de
suite allé sur la position
un bas relief a joué ses 4 1
tf6 et c3 où il parle il joue plutôt
langue anglaise voilà ça sera donc une
partie anglaise par ailleurs de mettre
ressemble un tas d'options en d4
voilà tout de suite attiré lemay en d3
affichant tout de suite sa volonté de
lutter contre contre les stars viennent
enfin de ne pas lutter contre la neige
qui n'a pas joué l'italienne il veut
absolument rien dire sauf illogique de
barrières ah oui c'est le c'était
également le choix de gourévitch y lire
quand ils voulaient faire nul contre
caen ce ghetto qui la travaillent tout
et non il n'avait pas réussi par deux
fois il y avait eu par deux fois la
russie 2 5 n'ont joué avec eux trois ici
bas relief de roeschwoog 3 et voilà
c'est fait au 4e 4 alors ça c'est un
coup responsable stéphane
affaiblissement net a fait briller dans
ce n'est qu'à la casse des quatre donc
le cavalier ses six plus tard pourra
peut-être venir sur cette tresse des
quatre voilà exactement le cavalier peut
envisager devient soir cette case des 4
pourquoi bien parce qu'elle ne peut plus
être défendu par les pions les pions ne
revenant pas en arrière et bing ne
peuvent pas redescendre pour venir
contre la casse des 4 je suis dit que le
gars a joué décisif c'est un coût de
développement normal baryal choc cavani
géant eux deux et maintenant on attend
soit cassée si ce soit un coup comme fou
aussi ce qui est également possible
à noter que l'idée de bas relief dans
cette position on voit toutes les
missions à venir au 2e et powell 3 ça va
être stéphane de pousser pions f en f4
et éventuellement ans et 5 mois la
meilleure façon de faire nul c'est quand
même de jouer agressif c'est vrai c'est
vrai c'est vrai la meilleure défense est
l'attaqué pour faire nul il faut jouer
pour le gain c'est le meilleur moyen d'y
arriver mais je vais dire aucune
barailla c6 joué par judit polgar sur
quoi barria froch et là je dis tout à 6
c'est une très bonne réaction elle veut
jouer avec b 5 commence à mettre la
pression sur l'option c4 ça se joue au
niveau de la structure de pions et on
sait que iossif dorfman connais très
très bien ce genre d'opposition et il
dit d'ailleurs que les blancs doit jouer
dynamique
ça veut dire que c'est les blancs qui
doivent chercher tout de suite à
justifier leur choix doivent
expliquer pourquoi ils ont placé leurs
pions comme ça laissant la case des
quatre libre d'accès pour les noirs et
donc il faut qu'ils réagissent vite
bara diouf devrait jouer un coup
agressif normalement ne pas se contenter
de jouer des petits coups ici b4 très
curieux ça secoue stéphane rey très
curieux parce que de toute façon dans le
noir veut jouer deux des cinq
oui donc ce qui n'empêche pas les cinq
espions peut s'avérer faible
alors attention parce que barnier fait
une énorme compréhension des positions
positionnelle justement des positions où
il faut jouer stratégique et donc ce
qu'il joue bekkat ce n'est certainement
pas un hasard mais ça a pas l'air d'être
le meilleur coup à noter la cadence de
jeu qui est rapide
les joueurs jouent vite les georges au
très vite judit polgar que l'on voit ici
à l'écran et bien elle est très très
rapide puisqu'elle n'a fléchi que de
minutes et bas reliefs à lui réfléchit
une minute trente
ça va très vite les joueurs on voit les
coûts ça déroule au rythme dans la
partie stéphane royer gorille ça joue
assez vite
effectivement alors que nous sommes
rejoints par bob james fischer robert
robert fontaine champion de france 99
junior et champion de france 2000 junior
aussi ému rebonjour valoir stéphane
alors que penses tu du robert du choix
de bas relief de jouer une anglaise emma
c'est un choix assez intelligent puisque
lui une nul lui suffit et d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'il avait joué contre etienne
donc il ne change pas ses habitudes ses
habitudes qui pour l'instant gagne oui
c'est vrai il avait joué ça contre
etienne pour faire nul dans la deuxième
partie qu'il avait également remporté
avec les pièces noires alors la barrière
est en train de réfléchir ça fait plus
d'une minute qui réfléchit donc on se
demande ce qu'il a envie de jouer le
dernier coup de judit polgar n'étant pas
vraiment un coup curieux c'est le couffo
aussi ce donc que veut faire barrière
quels sont les plans dans cette position
c'est toutes les questions qu'on peut se
poser et robert eh bien oui à mon avis
pour le gars va essayer tout simplement
de jouer fcf 5 c'est à dire enlever le
cas
m6 soit en et 8 soit en h5 en fait avait
elle s'est jouée le plan de l'east
indienne est loin c'est possible elle
peut également envisager de jouer 17 b 5
je ne sais pas si tu étais là au stage
de yossef dorfman où il expliqué ce
dessin qu'on analyse en sa partie contre
auch stephenson je n'y étais pas il ya
sylvie tordjman
et quand même champion de cette
ouverture est dit qu'il faut jouer avec
des 5 pour les noirs et que c'est le
problème
mais bon on va voir j'ai déployé revient
deux fois 6 à noter quand elle jouera ce
fameux coup mais c'est le destin qui est
dir est pilonnera le pion c4 c5 et on
peut dire thématiques dans cette
position peut-être que barrière va jouer
à 2 à 4 pour empêcher secoué loi tout
simplement à la brigade à 2 et 4
effectivement c'est une proposition avec
l'idée d'ailleurs de choses des cinq
mais c'est difficile de jouer l'attaqué
côté gauche de l'échiquier pour les
blancs sachant que le pion au cas très
bien elle bloque le foot j'ai 2 on
dirait que positionne helmand j'ai fini
par y fait fausse route
alors qu'on sait que je positionne elle
c'est comme sa spécialité dont l'une
très très curieux à noter que pôle gare
peut aussi par la suite tenté une
rupture au centre par la poussée des six
dessins ont pour l'instant évidemment
c'est pas possible
mais s'ils y arrivent à jour ça peut
faire très très mal ce coup
effectivement alors ça joue vite la sage
où il ya eu un enchaînement de coups à 4
le coût proposé par robert est là comme
tu dit robin robert tu as tout compris
qui avait 10 h 50 jeudi travailleurs
soient joués avec f5 cette fois avec
elle cinq très très probable ans est une
libération centrale en rupture sur le
put sur le centre sur le piémont 4 sur
la case de 4
et oui alors menaces en f4 pour
peut-être exactement à vii menacera f4
et on voit mal bas relief réagir en
jouant avec quatre lui même puisque il
se serait quand même très affaiblissant
il commencerait à être affaibli de tous
les côtés oui doit laisser la taille
mais c'est pas possible tout simplement
à cause d'un v6 l'échec
et oui chorégraphe y ont notamment
baissé ce qui viendrait faire échec au
roi c'est le pion à bouger et qui
prendrait le pire des cas de cancers au
contraire compliqué parce qu'il y est
tombé ensuite qui récupérera 7 mai
effectivement fait attention à ce genre
de manas est par ailleurs dos à dos
a développé son attaque à l d'âme parce
que pauvre gars on voit mal comment on
peut l'empêcher d'attaquer donc il faut
réagir à la dame en jouant b4 b5 et pour
cela il faut développer le phocéen pour
les jets les retours ou pour lier un peu
toutes les pièces blanches
le problème de bessengue c'est que après
apprend b5 et bien on peut par contre du
pur roi puisque la torah un sort étant
prises dans l'autre tour donc ici bas
relief doit chercher des solutions soit
pour préparer le coupe des quatre des
cinq soit pour anticiper la vence
d'edouard en f5
je dirais que positionnement c'est
judith qui est dans le vrai lit si elle
est dans le vrai mais barrail
affectionne ce genre de position moi je
vois bien un coup quand vous poussez un
à trois pour essayer de leur barrage
aller jouer à 4 à 5 des 5 b c'est un cas
il le joue quand même un dessin quand
même curieux une surprise une vraie
surprise dans sa vie ni celle de centre
la part sur pied le premier 5
c'est vrai puisque après le mariage
serait obligé de rentrer du pion c est
des 6 et 7 peut suivre oui où on va
laisser la structure noir comme ça et on
contrôle pas mal de cases au centre
c'est très curieuse que fait barrière
très très curieux je dit que le gars va
vraisemblablement prendre avec la fureur
le voit qui jette un oeil à l'écran
géant des pays-bas et daf est donc ici
après b5 et bien on ne voit pas ce qui
va on ne comprend pas on ne comprend pas
son idée à bas relief tout simplement
oui on peut comprendre quand même c'est
qu'il a essayé d'ouvrir beldame pour
essayer d'échanger un maximum de pièces
à la lame et ainsi soulager la pression
en tout cas paul garrel elle va attaquer
la loi c'est sûr elle peut même le faire
maintenant par f7 f5 le plan le plan
le plan logique après le coup de
cavaliers en a chaque c'est vrai mais
vrai sur le genre entre comme prendra
d'abord prendre un bus est mis en fait
je suis pas si sûr c'est bon de ce soit
avant de prendre des mois oui puisque
que mona ce barème vraiment halal damman
et bien je pense oui effectivement une
prise en c6 développerait le cavalier de
marjah en tout cas il pourrait reprendre
du pied tout simplement
oui c'est sûr donc oui pour l'instant
ils menacent pas grand chose les pays
bas relief mais enfin c'est pas parce
qu'il menace rien qui vaille sûr profité
d'une faute soit probablement viser
contre f5 parce qu'en cas de f5 on peut
prendre entre 5 et le fou j'ai deux se
libère sur la caste et 6 oui l'histoire
les par le pion b5 pour faire pression
sur la casse et 6 c'est possible c'est
possible mais ce n'est pas sûr
ce n'est pas sûr donc dans cette
position je ne sais pas donc on connaît
les plans maintenant on les a tous bien
mentionné le coup fcf 5
c'est une idée pour j'ai dit paul guerre
maintenant la question est ce qu'elle va
prendre en b5 d'abord à la ligne aile
centre et à la joue et f5 tout de suite
l abri lui il a pris effet d'image des
sans idées puis en pro f 5 c'est le coût
normal dans cette pression le couple est
divorcé et là on peut prendre souhaite
une pièce soit l'option du pion
production c'est plus pour l'attack mais
c'est affaiblissant le roi jeudi le gars
est un peu affaibli à noter qu'on aime
bien sa position j'ai dit ici
oui tu aimes bien parce que tu es un
genre de destin diane c'est vrai cette
position te corresponde parfaitement
mais marié flux peut-être préfère sa
position on peut supposer poussé à 3
lassant
le deuxième fut blanc sur une alors je
pense que d'abord il faut prononcer si
soyez tout à fait pareil à flamatt
évidemment il faut évidemment qu'on se 6
les noirs meubles menace positionnelle
c'était c6 c5 maintenant c'est éliminer
je comprends tu puis on prend là je me
suis dit où elle peut prendre du
cavalier prendre le cavalier laisserait
la case des cinq très très faible et loi
c'est vrai c'est cette case là quand on
reproduction il n'y a pas de souci on la
protège qu'entreprend du cavalier bien
ne la protège pas et oui à noter que sur
pions prendre les cavaliers b8 aura du
mal à sortir
ça c'est un problème mais est ce qu'il
aura besoin de sortir puisqu'on pourra
après pions prend ses six passes il a
tout rond à 7 puis éventuellement
angers7
après avoir déplacé le fou je pense que
ben arafa a bien joué a bien joué à la
phase qui vient de suivre puisqu'il
ouvre la laverie libéral après les pions
il ouvre la colonne b pour sa tour aussi
maria on va pouvoir jouer tour b 1 donc
cette clause rien fois trois mois je
préfère les blancs c'est vrai c'est vrai
ce les blancs ont l'air mieux pourquoi
parce que tous les pions de judith et
bien sont un peu faiblard et puis on
sait si c'est des 6es la taxe n'a pas
réellement commencer il attaque de
chenilles pulga est difficile à décrire
mais elle peut attaquer avec f4 quand
même c'est un beau coup d' attaque le
coût est de 5 et 4
c'est la menace de judit polgar
puisqu'après f4 on menace f3 fourchette
et barrier le joueur 4 il a prévu dit il
se prémunit contre la menace de judit
polgar à noter que robert qu'est ce qui
s'passe surtout en fonction des
champions champion il suivra tout
simplement champions puis en profession
qui surprend pions c'est un échange
on ne peut pas prendre autrement puisque
le fou g7 se réveille quand même avec le
télé ces trois là judith est
complètement dans son élément parce que
j'ai dit on sait qu'à calcule tout très
vite elle qu'elle très bien les drones
tactiques et bas relief puis oublié
quelque chose dans cette position
puisqu'on voit des possibilités des
chèques sur la grande diagonale et celle
là on voit des possibilités avec le fou
g7 sur l'autre diagonale donc ça fait
tout ça un agent possibilités le cabinet
c3 qui est en prise
la tour 1 qui est aussi aux prises et le
roi qui est passerait bien placé tout ça
ça fait beaucoup d'éléments pour judit
polgar qui va cogiter dur et oui f4
c'est un coup thématique puisque c'était
le même coup qu'il avait employée contre
etienne bacrot dans la seconde partie il
avait réagi exactement de la même
manière donc bas relief sait où il va la
position de critique de la position
expliqué réfléchir et et judith est
revenue avec son cavalier à m6 elle
recycle son cavalier h5 qui était à la
bande cavaliers ou vendu 56 ça y est
c'est jouer demain j'ai dit aux gars
alors que le club de yutz nous regardent
et signalé sur le chat a lieu c'est un
club peu connu effectivement
yutz yacht donc bah nous les saluons
même si nous ne savons pas où c'est et
ils peuvent peut-être nous en dire plus
sur leur petit club qui est peut-être un
grand club d'ailleurs donc en club russe
vous c'est pas une petite ville de 50
millions d'habitants comme on en connaît
beaucoup en russie alors attention ça
joue sajou ou sajoo séjour ne nous
laissons pas distraire tourbe et un
tombé à manas tour bessède peut-être
menace tour d un an
bessette c'est effectivement c'est
l'idée de libérer neuf bulgares a ramené
son client m6 alors qu'elle est qu'elle
en était l'idée mais ce qu'avaient les
racheter avait fini son travail
oui il fallait être recyclés pour
contrôler le centre d'accord donc c'est
un combat centrale pour le moment c'est
un combat centrale donc maintenant je
suis dit que le gars est ce qu'elle
envisage de jouer le coup au 5e car dans
cette version a priori non c'est pas
possible
donc qu'est-ce qu'elle envisage de jouer
c'est comme problématique c'est
l'apathie d1a panier
judit polgar n'aurait-elle pas d'idées
elle vous récents il et on peut se poser
la question alors peut-être on va
profiter de ce petit temps mort pour
jeter un oeil sur les joueurs en grand
voilà il est le gars ni barrière voilà
un plan central avec les deux joueurs
sur la scène du grand auditorium à
cannes c'est les demi finales du
championnat du monde deux parties
rapides d'échec très très gros match il
finit par ailleurs c'est un russe il est
dans les dix meilleurs mondiaux depuis
des années mais il n'a jamais réussi à
exploser complètement il n'a jamais
réussi à battre les meilleurs il est
donc dans la deuxième chose c'est un
joueur de seconde zone mais du top
niveau évidemment judit polgar c'est la
meilleure joueuse du monde depuis
qu'elle est née pratiquement en flux en
tout cas on n'a pas souvenir de
l'ancienne joueuse avant elle depuis
qu'elle a 16 ans elle est numéro un
mondial
c'est vraiment très impressionnant donc
ces deux bons joueurs pour une belle
partie on rappelle que ça se joue en
deux manches que la première a été
remportée par l'ilga ni barrières et que
judit polgar doit donc impérativement
gagner impérativement gagner si elle
veut égaliser dans ce match et aller
dans les blitz de départage passer ces
petites précisions vous pouvez nous
faire vos commentaires sur le chat et
vous posez des nouvelles questions
on va revenir sur la top position et
faire un petit bilan pendule il reste 19
minutes et j'ai dit que le gars 17
minutes 30 à divulguer ni bas relief
donc judith et mieux autant lité muse
elle a joué tour à 7
et oui elle se bat
ce prêt mais elle s'est promenée j'ai
cherché mon ce2 à munich en tournée
cette paix et cette tour va pouvoir
coulisser sur le 7e manger oui c'est un
vrai dire en bref cette par exemple
citons coulissement tout à fait voire
même un coulissage chu de rouen
tout à fait et barise peut jouer fou
c'est un à trois ans menaçant tout
simplement plus on prend 1,5 et un petit
clouage proposition de robert pour
revenir de bas reliefs poussé sur la
casa 3 qui fera donc une pression sur le
plan des six éventuellement sur la toit
fuit et qui menacera donc directement
pions prend pions en eux cinq traits la
menace donc voilà le truc x 3 c'est un
bon coup effectivement que viviani
barrière pourrait jouer évidemment ils
pourront jouer d'autres il peut jouer
pour trois et peut jouer et puis on
prend 1,5 tout de suite il peut
peut-être même jouer des quatre étaient
quatre c'est plus chaud beaucoup de
possibilités pour voir ja fils va donc a
priori prendre son temps et ça c'est bon
pour judith et oui c'est bon pour j'ai
dit à moi qui regarde évidemment et que
bas relief réfléchissent et finissent
par le trouver ce qui ça ne serait pas
bon du tout pour judith a noté kissy la
salle donc et un peu moins remplie que
pour kasparov
évidemment que ce parc est chaud que
c'est l affiche du jour mais quand même
le public est une famille qu'ils avaient
encore la fille du jour puisqu'il ya le
match départagera 22h entre les deux
joueurs
c'est sûr ça va être hyper chaud alors
barnett va jouer deux fois 3 bien vu
robin décidément son style positionnelle
s'accordent bien celui de bas relief
puisque tu trouves tous ses coups pas
mal donc la pression la menace des
blancs c'est de prendre avec le pion
entre 4,25 et s'il est noir reprennent
eh bien c'est la tour et suite qui
patine puisque le fou pourrait
l'apprendre
donc il faut que je dis tu sois liquide
en f4 mai puis on prend 1,4 serait
qui positionne elle puisque bahreïn
pourrait reprendre du cavalier attaquant
il faut aussi ce ou alors je retour aux
huit peut-être oui oui ça ça paraît plus
logique il faut grâce au melon ceux des
clous et ou alors bougez lecavalier mais
je ne sais pas moi je pense qu'il va
jouer tour au 8 juin dit voici un été
que tour ff7 serait mauvais puisque par
life ça devrait attaquer le cavaliere et
huit par dame b3 et ainsi profiter la
colonne mais ça veut dire que il faut
tenir la huitième ranger voilà le mythe
et manger c'est également important à
tenir la 7e et la 8e s'il est orangée
qui fonctionne en tenir donc là si on se
réfère aux critères de yossi dorfman la
structure de psion est avantageuse pour
bas relief varié puisque je dis tu as
des pions faible en c6 et des six la
position du roi est avantageuse pour
barrière pareilles f puisque il a trois
pions devant le roi alors que je visite
dans a que deux effectivement et
qu'est-ce qu'il ya d'autres le matériel
matériel égal est égale effectivement
judith arrive à tenir sur le point
matériel donc une loi on peut en
conclure que marc aillet fait un petit
avantage alors que ça s'est mis à jouer
beaucoup plus vite qui a vu tours 8 de
jouer d'amd de effectivement barrier
fait un peu mieux tours fc
je suis dit a remis sa tour en offset et
là bas relief il s'en fout il dit tour b
2 judy tu n'as pas d' attaque
tu me fais rien vas-y m'étais pièces
près de trois mois je j'ai un plomb je
vais jouer tout répond bien et je fait
attaquer donc été vite avec mon fou g2
qui pilonne champions 7 6 eh oui si
pareille fenêtre sur la 7ème ça va être
très dur pour un regard c'est vrai c'est
sur cette position difficile pour judit
polgar il est fort ce bas relief
il est très fort on rappelle quelques
détails sur ce joueur
il a remporté deux fois de suite le
tournoi de tilburg qui est le plus fort
tournoi à élimination directe le tournoi
de référence ont émis cette élimination
directe il a donc les nerfs solides et
on président d'ab l'on peut aussi dire
qu'il est dans une phase de forme depuis
depuis la seconde et crame nico match
comme ni kasparov
il a fait une très bonne prestation à
new delhi et là on le revoit encore en
de la coupe du monde ce sommet rapide
ici à cannes le délice c'était le
champion du monde deux parties de langue
ça l'a fait problème c'est que l'on voit
pas trop quel coup que je vois judith la
logique c'est un problème c'est
effectivement le problème alors que
l'ordinateur est en train de dire nate
avantage pour parier petit avantage
oui le problème de poids bien c'est
qu'elle peut pas elle peut pas créer
vraiment de menaces là on ne peut pas
créer une rupture au centre puisque tous
ses pions sont fixés par marc et f
donc si elle peut pas créer une rupture
au sens il faudrait qu'elle attaque avec
ses pièces et c'est pas facile du tout
ce qui est pas facile c'est de bouger
une pièce dans cette position alors on
regarde les pièces une à une le fou g7
on peut pas le déplacer la tour eiffe
cet a priori non plus là toi vite non
plus lequel les baby qui peut pas bouger
parce qu'elles purent ses 600 prises
la dame a pas vraiment de cases on sait
pas trop comment j'ai dit peut améliorer
la position de ces pièces est en tout
cas ce qu'on sait c'est qu'elle peut pas
améliorer la position derrière alors
c'est vraiment judith va pêcher en eaux
troubles
voilà genre h 7 h 5 pour essayer de
faire la de commencer en tout cas oui
j'aime bien ce coût aux cinq
effectivement le courage 5 pour me jouer
h4 et affaiblir la position dure en
blanc alors que nous avons une
proposition de notre président donc
jacques cros l'homme qui est sur le chat
et qui propose le coup eux 5 e 4 pour
judith un coup tactique
objectivement c'est possible c'est ça va
dans le sens de l'opposition notre
accord oui mais je lui dis c'est
possible puisque si les plans prennent
en quatre
alors on va on va montrer la variante
une spéciale dédicace à notre président
bien-aimé e 4 donc il y aurait 20 198
reprend 1,4 mais qu'est ce qu'il y
aurait d'autres et d'ailleurs je prends
ce matin après un 4 sélections c4 qui
est faible il ya toujours ces cartes
emprise mais le pion des six aussi est
faible ouais mais là on peut reprendre
le cadre tout simplement voilà
mondialisation et c'est à l'option des
six est emprisonné effectivement robert
il faut prendre avec lecavalier et on
voit que ici le fou g7 se réveille le
cabillaud qui attaquent la dame attaque
aussi le cas et c'est 3
ces chaussettes position c'est tout
simplement mon laxisme et judith ne l'a
pas joué je dis tu ne l'as pas jouer des
loyers et ben on lui dira après la
partie on lui dira judit polgar le coup
et 4 allait bien dans le sens même si
cette philippe séguin fut le seul
avantage
des avantages c'est que ça ne menaçait
rien si on faisait rien avec le banc par
exemple tous rêvent bien tous et vous
pouvez jouer des cinq après robert
pouvait jouer des saintes est enfermé
ainsi le fou j'ai deux c'était possible
c'était possible avec dams est joué
alors j'ai dit aux gars qui ne prend pas
de risque en fait il ne prend pour
l'instant pas ses responsabilités au
sérieux puisqu'elle est obligé de gagner
on le rappelle donc je dit paulien fait
peut-être un peu fausse route
elle se fait masser par baril c'est un
massage russe c'est pas les lois la loi
est la loi
une petite idée pour marin pour paul car
elle va jouer damas cet échec et cavalli
g41 et elle ne fait pas forcément fausse
route la perverse damas cet échec qui
ferait un échec au roi l'horoscope donc
obligé de partir sur les th 1 et là il y
aurait peut-être qu'elle g4 avec un
cavalier qui rentreraient soit 11,3 soit
en f2 avec un gros effet c'est donc un
coup tactique de judit polgar oui oui
oui tout à fait tout à fait bien vu être
commence à faire des petites menaces tu
dit on rappelle qu'il faut pas beaucoup
de pièces pour faire des magasins
elle peut faire de la magie avec pas
grand chose et oui avec rien mais oui
elle a des arguments de ce côté-là judit
polgar elle est très vive être calcul
très vite un rien peut faire balancer la
position c'est sûr ça change rapidement
la position peut se retourner très vite
rouch un bas relief croît chaque si oui
il se prémunit contre l'échec de judith
maintenant si vous vous dites douces et
cette dame à cette femme à 7
eh bien il pourra jouer peut-être comme
h3 je ne sais pas ou alors il pourra
voir venir disons qu'ils gagnent du
temps je te faut acheter ce qui est
proposé par l'ordinateur qui a pas l'air
d'être un mauvais coup dans cette
position stéphane ça cloue la dame
justice c'est pas mal ça met de la
pression il ya du jeu peut-être à stein
d'abord peut-être h55 c'est un coup
qu'on a envie de jouer effectivement
dans ce genre de produit maintenant que
le roi et en h1 l'ouverture dans la
colonne âge peut être dangereux pour
marié et oui elle va sûrement jouer h5
judith elle commence à tarauder zilok
elle commence à trouver des trucs la
petite judith on va voir bilan pendule
14 minutes chacun et qualité absolue
dont pronostiqué loi pour cette partie
pronostique une boucherie d'un hors jeu
ne s'est passé c'est une position très
complexe tout tout devient possible
en tout cas c'est vrai qu'on aimerait
bien quand même que judith l'emportent
mais bon ben ya fille n'est pas facile à
noter que robert me fait signe qu'il est
pour bright f
oui pourquoi pas cavalli b17 ouhlala je
crois qu'elle fait vraiment faux ce
compte là julie celle conduisant un coq
curieuse on espère transitoire et ça
restera un bon tour et fb un menaçant de
tomber c'est tout simplement mal on voit
jouer torbey 8
oui mais changer les pièces facilite
enfin arrange barrière en tout cas ce
qui n'a besoin que la f1 on a vu que
quand on l'essayé trop de faire nul
on a vu hier que ça pouvait amener à des
problèmes
la sas a pas l'air bon ça a pas l'air
bon il va il a joué pour fb un bas
relief évidemment un peu petit moins
qu'avant night en paix c'est la guerre
il y menacent d'entrer complètement dans
la position noir oui à noter qu'à
valider ça tu ne peux pas bouger
puisqu'il pourra suivre tourbe et six
attaquants purs ceci c'est vrai qu'on
menace centré sur plusieurs cases donc
ici c'est dur il ya beaucoup de pression
le four à 3 qui fait pression aussi je
lui dis tu n'as pas trouvé les mots n'a
pas trouvé les coups pour bien réagir si
ici il faut je tombais 8 c'est pas bon
du tout ça se passe très mal
grosse pression de barrières
conspiration alors est-ce que cavalier
c5 qui avait laissé cinq il y a
puis on prend pion aux 5 et c'est fini
tout de suite
l'ordinateur annonce déjà un gros
avantage et qui ont gardé cet été un
coup un peu qu'est-ce qu'elle a joué les
choix curieux gérer passionnant qu'est
ce qu'elle a fait des cinq thés diack
des six des 5
elle craque elle craque ou en tout cas à
laisser l ess est enflammé un peu la
position n'a la menace positionnelle cd4
la question c'est que se passe-t-il sur
tours 17
et d'autres questions que va jouer
pareil f alors pourquoi est-ce qu'elle a
joués ce coup des 5 et bien première
chose il fallait faire quelque chose
il fallait faire quelque chose et le
problème c'est que quand la tour venait
en b 7 6 la table repartant des 8 où on
s'est vite et bien le pion des six
auraient été en prise quand il était là
donc déjà elle sauve son pion ça c'est
le premier pan le deuxième point c'est
que c'est une réaction saine au centre
une des idées peut être de jouer soit 2
5 4 qui on fermera le fou j'ai deux soit
des cinq des quatre qui commencera à
chasser le cavalier de ces trois ça
c'est possible aussi beaucoup d'idées
pour judit polgar mais maintenant et
qu'ils laissent ma fille je vais tomber
cette il envoie tour 17
évidemment posant la question à la dame
de judit polgar où va la dame où tu vas
voilà ce qui lui dit peut-être rien 5 15
à 5 pourquoi pas ça a l'air plus
intéressant que les cases s'est vite ou
des vite que je mets en rouge parce
qu'elles sont pas joli du tout ces cases
sont pas joli mais on a noté qu'il ya un
piège sur 2008
il ya un petit piège qu'il faut faire
auquel elle a calé auquel il faut faire
attention c'est fou des six menace en
retour des 8
c'est une marche aux abats
malheureusement puisque après qu'est
manip entoure la dame pourrait aller sur
la case de 17 ha oui donc un petit piège
qui n'en est pas un un petit viège qui
ne marche pas c'est un piège parce que
justement parier pourrait tomber dedans
en se disant que ça marche il enfin donc
je ne sais pas ce que va changer dit
elle a dû répondre à la réponse d'amd
vite
le troisième coup d'avion des 8 et david
derepas s'est positionné lmnp la loi
comme plus on croit 5 par exemple pour
laisser la case f4 aux cavaliers aux
camaïeux 2 où il reste il va sans doute
futur proche bien entendu ça à l'air
d'être le bon coup dans cette position
puisque après ou alors qu'ils étaient
plus 11,5 et bien le cas au lieu de
ressorts soins des quatre soirs f4
wissous alors prendre en d5 puis le 5
mai histoire de soulager un peu la
pression au centre c'est une autre
possibilité
je ne sais pas mais en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que nous allons refaire
notre petit jeu d'évaluation la
structure de pions et toujours mieux
pour bas relief la position du roi est
toujours meilleur au braille f et le
matériel toujours égale donc évidemment
un avantage mariage alors qu'à la
pendule iachini par ailleurs prend un
petit peu de retard il a deux minutes de
retard maintenant il reste 13 minutes et
judith et 11 appareils f donc je dis tu
peux espérer l'enfumer servi par arias
n'a pas forcément les nerfs trop solide
si jamais il a plus beaucoup de temps et
bien il peut se faire avoir
et oui car la judith qui calcule rennes
micha et garonne de l'eshop c'est vrai
c'est comme ça pour l'appel donc pour
l'instant
peut-être c'est l'heure du clan sur les
joueurs un plomb joueurs avec voilà les
deux joueurs qui sont là sur scène 30
auditorium de cannes comme cadre
prestigieux
judit polgar la meilleure joueuse du
monde qui est tout rouge et en léopard
aujourd'hui et en face d'elle
nous avons fini bas relief cravate
chemise noire et la coupe des années
soixante dix des beatles et finit par y
est très concentré mais très efficace
aussi alors il joue et minibar eev nous
allons tout de suite voir ce qu'il se
passe je crois qu'il est pris à vos 5 il
a pris un des singles 5 décembre puis on
prend des cinq morts jeudi devra
semblant reprendre confiance et et puis
on croit 5 sera à suivre et bon avantage
blanc je préfère nettement et blanc
depuis c'est clair c'est clair que les
blancs sont mieux et blanc sont
évidemment mieux mais judith peut
trouver des choses elle a pris du
cavalier en d5 chevallier prend des 5
oui ça libère le fuji cesse salivaire un
petit peu ce fou maintenant payez plus
guerriers devant ils clament les devants
donc c'est passé pas si mauvais le coût
proposé par l'intense pression c'est fou
des six stéphane nous conclut est
proposé je ne sais pas
la position est vraiment complexe ici
vraiment très con mais je crois que rien
ne fait en rien au fait c'est ça reste
compliqué eh oui
à noter que sur pour le gars vous
échangez le fou aussi ce tout simplement
après cavaillé prendrait 5 fu prendre
les 5 et échanger le fou g2 qui protège
le roi blanc c'est doit être une de ses
idées elle veut attaquer de toutes
façons et avaient attaqué à la pas le
choix c'est sûr que le meilleur moyen de
gagner c'est quand même d'attaqué est
fou des six jeux par maria vraiment ce
bas relief est quand même un bon joueur
il faut bien le dire
il comprend très bien ce genre de
position donc la pression est très
complexe
je vous le cache pas si vous venez
d'arriver sur des gones al position
extrêmement compliqué on voit bien les
pièces qui s'embrouillent les unes dans
les autres
il ya eu très peu des changes on voit un
foot barrières on se demande ce qu'il
fait là quand même au plein coeur de
l'opposition noir et bien ce qu'il fait
il met de la pression sur le pion aux
cinq de judit polgar en fait il est par
ailleurs fait deux indirectement en fait
de libérer ce cavalier de libérer la
force potentielle de ces pièces il veut
que judith craquer bouge champions 2-5
et ensuite son colis pourra ressortir
soit en f4 soit en d4
voilà l'idée de marier avec son pouf ou
des six mais évidemment la position est
très très compliqué des pièces partout
les pièces vole un peu les pièces vol
oui alors que la bataille est faite en
grande réflexion
mais
alors que l'onu fait de grands gestes
tout à fait j'essaie de vous inciter à
parler mais c'est pas facile c'est pas
facile alors c'était fait un tabac de
questions sur le tchat
le président il à une question sur le
chat sommes-nous payée pour faire des
commentaires
question totalement indiscrètes
effectivement qui ne regarde que nous
effectivement on aime bien faire les
commentaires de toute façon voilà vous
allez sera la réponse qu'on l'a on
donnera cette question quels sont les
temps et loi tant réfection dix minutes
restantes pour bas relief dix minutes
restantes pour judit polgar et oui ça se
tient ça se tient ça va à noter que si
la position reste compliqué comme ça et
qui a plus que deux minutes par joueur
ouh là moi je donne le gard gaillon dans
l'eure gagnant puisque moi y attend plus
il ya de chances que judith arrive à
trouver des choses et on sait qu'en plus
de ça elle est vraiment redoutable elle
est redoutable et bar à yafa légèrement
craqué dans sa deuxième partie contre
bacrot puisque il avait une finale où il
a réussi à faire annuler facilement mais
il a quand même donné un pion il y avait
égalité de matériel en thaïlande etienne
a réussi à lui prendre un pion ce qui
prouve que il n'a pas forcément les
nerfs aussi solide ne s'inscrit que ça
oui mais il est très fort il y avait ni
barria fait sa grande force
évidemment c'est dans les parties
longues plus de temps pour réfléchir
plus il peut faire des plans élaborés et
complexe mais dès qu'il faut jouer vite
et que ça joue un peu
onair justement dès que ça devient très
compliqué il ya des petites combinaisons
à ado front des combinaisons en deux
courants en toc ou des trucs très simple
et bien là il n'est plus à 200% bas
relief il ne voit pas tout ils oublient
les choses et je dis tu peux faire la
différence
à noter que judith là et réfléchie elle
a un peu embêté maintenant il est
clairement on y vient jouer damas cinq à
marseille probablement le coup le plus
complexe
proposé par l'ordinateur en tout cas
clouage menace plus on prenait 4 suivi
d'une attaque triple en c3 ouais ou aux
quatre vingt quatre choix avec le
principe c'est que le fou g7 va venir at
et quelques essais 3 que kay des 5 la
taxe déjà et que la dame à 5
l'attak aussi et surtout que le câble et
ne peut pas bouger puisque la dame des
deux serait perdue qui te fait il ya un
clouage donc d'amazon c'est le bon coup
maintenant alors que l'ordinateur
proposent souvent aux cinq qui al'air
aberrant propre aux cavaliers aux quatre
cavaliers ou 4 c'est une façon de se
déployer stéphane façon peu connu
du grand public mais qui existe kallio 4
ça mais les dames emprise donc on ne
peut pas prendre le cavalier sinon la
dame prendra la dame
les six et les noirs qui viennent
prendre la dame blanche est bien le cas
mais qu'ils étaient en prison quatre
revient salaire de forcer les chargés
d'armes puisque sinon le coup cavalli g5
serait mort meurtrier c'est vrai en plus
ce qui veut dire quatre ça a l'air pas
mal
voilà ce coup qu'est venue de quatre
sacrifier un plus haut à 4 comment ça
suffit' turin 4 mai qui avait jugé cinq
effectivement revers comme l'a dit
stéphane c'est un coût qui fait mal très
mal
donnez un pion c'est par une grosse
compensation carioca t'échange les dames
donc facilite la tâche de bahreïn est
fait et ce qu'ils veulent jouer
il a pas mal de possibilités quand même
s'il est pas obligé de jouer
alors tous à jouer ça joue et il n'a pas
joué sa bas relief il a joué autre chose
quelque chose de très très curieuse si
j'en crois ce que je viens de voir il a
joué f-35 judit polgar a repris du
cavalier il a mûri avec le fou il a joué
fou prend cavalier est donc maintenant
il ya les fous contre les barrières
réfléchi et par exemple un col à jeudi
étaient revenus dans la partie là à sa
part est clair stéphane que du halal à
la pâte donné c'est fou comme ça à la
paire de fous où elles menacent f4
peut-être voyez elle menaçait le cas
tout à fait stéphane pour casser les
cases noires autour du roi blanc et je
dis tu vas jouer d'attac
je veux l'être avec maintenant et en
plus il ya toujours ce petit problème
pour bas relief c'est comme le cahier c3
qui est en crise la dame qui cloue la
dame
le cavaly qui attaquent le cavalier le
fou qui attaquent le cavalier et oui et
oui et oui oui à l'arrivée ou là où la
dame j'ai cinq échecs
alors attention peut-être qu'il a vu une
combinaison de nulle force inouïe c'est
de cloud tout simplement
il a peut-être eu nulle force est il
qu'il n'y paraît f pour g7 serait la
source des tours g7 qu'est ce qui se
passe sur trop g7 bas il se passe rien
stéphane et six tours j'ai plongé cette
salle je crois que ça deviendrait
rapidement après tout reprend tofu prend
et deuxième tours en 17 tours c'est un
tour g7 c'est ce coup non peut-être que
le coucou g7 et plus il faut g7
permettrait de restaurer 8 qui est
charge des tours et qui amène une tour
sur la huitième oui oh oui mais ça c'est
pas forcément si grave non je ne sais
pas là il faut que j'ai dit soient
précises maintenant il faut bien qu'elle
réfléchisse qu'est ce qui se passe
pareil va retourner la situation c'est
maintenant lui qui attaque judit polgar
essais judit polgar qui se retrouvent
mieux sur le long terme autant un bar
yaffa vent était en train de vie
c'est-à-dire qu'il avance et ses pièces
petit à petit sachant qu'il était mieux
dans le temps
maintenant c'est le contraire mari djata
jouer efficacement rapidement alors que
j'ai des polkas elle joue très vite
justement et je fous g7 et à la pendule
elle est mieux elle mieux elle a huit
minutes 20 et bas reliefs n'a plus que
sept minutes 40
olala ça irait c'est le royaume khallaf
comment va jouer très vite aussi il a la
main sur l'échiquier tomber vite tomber
vite c'était le coup de stéphane tout à
fait le coup de stéphane le coup qui
veut attaquer la huitième ranger c'est
un bon coup tomber vite
le cavalier en c3 et en prise mais je
dis tu ne peux pas le prendre parce que
justement cette huitième rang j'ai trop
affaibli et il y aurait donc des dégâts
graves pour à fait fluide serait serait
recommandable
mais je ne sais pas s'il va jouer
puisque sur touré fuite il ya toujours
un des 7 et 8 du sénat et ben arafa
trouver une attaque là il ya des chances
d'attac pour bas reliefs
à noter ici que l'on voit le roi de
bahreïn f parfaitement sécurisée puisque
il adoption devant lui un fouet à une
éventuellement chaotique pour revenir
alors que le roi de judith mon gars est
dans le vent donc toujours cet avantage
de position du roi la structure est on
toujours meilleur pour bright est donc
maintenant le la compensation que j'ai
dit c'est qu'elle a pris la peur de vous
et oui il faut que paul garraud
réussissent à échanger et doit
maintenant après quoi la tâche sera
beaucoup plus facile mais là on voit mal
avec sa dame aura 5 comment elle peut
revenir
et oui elle est un peu égaré cette dame
là qu'est ce que j'aurais d'ailleurs
si la ville était garé et perdu
ordinateurs proposent tout reprend tour
tan tan toronto recouvre ce qui ne
donnera donc cela tout reprend tout
reprend tours fc est en fuite
on tombe et 7 ans 8 mais là
effectivement pas de problème pour
barrier à phil conserverait l'avantagent
donc avantage bas relief toujours la
paire de fou n'a pas l'air de compenser
pleinement cette initiative de bas
relief la pression sur le roi et
l'avantagent la structure de pions il
est fort bas relief
il est fort maintenant il faut que je
dis que lui mettre la pression autant
elle vient d'où il est fou c'est vite
bien joué elle ne veut pas échangé deux
pièces les charges aucune pièce judit
polgar à la raison mais la mariette
prolonge ou écarts et les pompiers
vallier si on prend et qui me dit f4
avis se heurterait à un matt furtif le
matin en attendant il reste 7 minutes à
chacun ça va s'accélérer maintenant ça
chauffe ça chauffe ça va vite ça va vite
seulement 27e coup et oui ça va
commencer à devenir très chaud robert
vraiment très chaud ouais ouais ça va se
jouer sur le matin on attend
impatiemment que ça va jouer sur les
nerfs cette fin de partie
c'est ça qu'on aime c'est commencer sur
les nerfs c'est ça qui est beau c'est
tout c'est pour ça que les échecs sont
vraiment un sport à part entière c'est
quand ça se joue aux nerfs alors que
nous avons la partie qui se déroule
tranquillement polgar contre barrières
et dans quelques minutes ça va
s'accélérer nettement
il a commencé à chauffer voilà bas
relief il a trouvé un truc il va prendre
des cintres quel point qui avait dit ça
il a joué coupe je lui dit va reprendre
avec l'option tempo c'est fait et là
c'est à bahreïn à vivre car d'enchaîner
avec il a joué qu'avec des cartes non
non non il a joué le coup h3 alors
évidemment c'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure sur cavaliers f4 il y avait
toujours un échec qui posait
éventuellement des problèmes donc parié
de ce prévenu zhu h3 faisant une petite
caste de fuite pour le roi petites cases
et paul garde va prendre les cavaliers
eu deux puisque évidemment le fossé
s'est vite serait sans défense et ça
c'est très grave
donc voilà barre élève toujours mieux
toujours mieux il ya bibard adiaffi il
faudrait que je dis tu arrives à activer
sa dame de toute façon elle travaille là
dessus je dit pas il ya un petit coup
comme achi c'est loi serait pas mal pour
demander un dame blanche où aller
exactement
donc c'est très bien qui a viré au rouge
et six et l'iran g6 ma ce moment là
maintenant pour revenir en d2 et c'est
un être très intéressant très
intéressant alors oui un petit peu pour
replacer la dame noire sur la caisse des
deux a aimé sa tanière pour l'ambitieux
la case blanche et contrôlée
on propose on qui agissent pour matane à
manger si c'est ensuite venir en d2 et
finir problème de kurdes et s'inquiètant
prise alors alors que le club d'échecs
de le spc inoussa lui eh bien nous les
saluons également évidemment beaucoup de
plats d'un beau couple reçoit beaucoup
de clubs
on suppose que les connexions sont
faites dans les clubs ce qui veut dire
que le nombre de gens qui regardent
probablement beaucoup sur bien supérieur
au nombre d'utilisateurs connectés
évidemment stéphane évidemment donc peu
importe de toute façon l'important c'est
que ce show must go 1 h 6 h 6 damage 5
d'un match 5 pourquoi on va acheter un
cas là ils arrêtent de poète fou g7 mais
en revanche c'est plus la tour à vii
maintenant barrière oui puisque tu as
trop vite serait temps prises avec deux
tours sont cloués les deux tours sans
pleurer puisque oui voilà il ya un beat
louaj trilatérale et ça c'est du grand
sport la menace de barrières maintenance
et cavalières 4 on voit mal ce que je
dis tu peux faire contre ça elle est
vissé est lévis et diaby bryant n'a pas
lâché sa proie pour l'instant il reste
six minutes à bahreïn cinq minutes à
judit polgar oui ici variable gagné 2 0
ce serait la première fois de sa serai à
trois compétitions
oui tout à fait pour l'instant il n'y a
eu que des seins et demi 1/2 ou un
partout effectivement peut-être que
variable peut gagner 2-0 enfin toute
façon ces bonus ça ne sert à rien ouais
ça ne sert strictement à rien un ennemi
ou 2 0 c'est pareil ça ne compte pas
pour le classement elo ça car ça
complique la semaine deux parties
rapides white respect par thierry qui
pour l'instant n'est pas tout à fait
reconnu puisqu'il ya très peu de classe
et wyatte repas de classe et les
meilleurs de ce cinquième numéro 1
parties rapides
c'est laurent frayssinet je crois et
c'est à vérifier puisque il a plus de
2800 en partie semi rapides mois c'est
énorme c'est c'est tout à fait
considérable d'ailleurs c'est surprenant
mais bon il faut voir le classement des
autres joueurs moi je ne connais que
celui de laurent frayssinet cet
emplacement une évaluation française
donc pas forcément reconnus par la fidh
et enfin peu importe pour l'instant ce
qui nous importe c'est t'y vas jouer la
finale et ça on le saura après cette
partie un vilain pendule pour t'aider
demandez vite faut bien générer des
coûts ici c'est pas forcément facile
des cinq sur camille laisser aller elle
a déclaré la toile cette fois le
problème c'est que la tour est surchargé
au québec quatre de brailler fait
évidemment by f
là on voit tout de suite que la
présidence jeudi rang des cinq n'est
plus qu'une ruine et la cfu prend des 5
c'est vrai robert il ya beaucoup de
menaces il ya beaucoup de menaces paria
fils s'amuse dans cette position et
dansé on a l'impression que judith pour
l'instant et la joffo 5
mon séjour vite la salle ovide aux
petits intéressant très intéressant
autant pour moi il ya eu une petite
cagade et maria fin je me tout reprend
fous ces huit tours sacrifie et fou
prend des 5
voilà le à la rate et voilà ça c'est
terminé c'est fini c'est un coup de
massue de yves bény bail avec titre
combinaison de marc hayek qui simplifie
maintenant la dame hi5 attaque la toile
cette le full attack aussi et cette
requête est à venir elle est clouée est
d'alger si suis peut-être d'une
perpétuelle puisqu'il peut se permettre
une perpétuelle on est tout à laquelle
un échec perpétuel il peut aussi prendre
le clavecin et c'est fini là c'est
terminé petite combinaison hal a raté sa
judith c'est sûr c'est sûr mais sa
position était de toute façon très très
difficile à noter que l'ordinateur
annonce ce matin un avantage d
équivalent à 5 pions pour bas relief
c'est donc considérable il lui reste
cinq minutes à barrière et judith ayant
réfléchi beaucoup pour jouer tour des
mythes la faute ne verse que trois
minutes
et oui ce serait bien que bahreïn gagne
alors elle se bat judith quand même elle
se bat elle joue le coup tour
évidemment j'ai six échecs cuisants et
c'est fini mais maintenant effectivement
ouvert après d'objets six échecs c'est
nul minimum pour marc aillet fait ça lui
suffit au moins un échec perpétuelle
pour bahreïn f pas surya fou g7 run mais
il vous prend elle s'était tournée 8 et
mat
je crois que il a joué d'investissement
enfin si la joie d'alger si je dis tu
vas jouer foucher 7 évidemment tous
gagnent la foule g77 obligé d'avaler h5
par exemple alors le food et
s'inquiètent en prise avec échec robert
attention et wim van de blague
il peut jouer tour bessette par exemple
vous prend tour il a fait faux protour
échec
normalement la tour reprend et
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'il fait nuit
bahreïn est bien la tourbe évite tout
simplement qu'ils gagnent en ligne touré
fuite après tout reprend tour cavalli
aussi ces chèques qui comprend le fou g7
en tout cas il ne peut plus perdre
barailla film ne peut plus perdre les
question c'est est-ce qu'il va vouloir
gagner à tout prix
non il va y passe contre tottenham c'est
vraiment je pense qu'il va prendre la
balle et un final tourbez vite et chaque
au roi torah fuite de judith et là que
se passe-t-il tourcoing tours qui a valu
aux 6,1 l'abandon et le juge vide est
très probable on reprend tournerait peut
se permettre un échec perpétuelle leur
îlot il arrive à proposer nul qu'ils
oublient aussi ses propose nul 5 revers
à f
et non je dis 'je vous ai je dit la joue
elle n'abandonne pas comme ça j'ai dit
molière nul ça ira ça y est quel projet
7 et parties nulles s'éteignent la
position finale est loin a noté c'est
fini c'est fini c'est fini il ya
peut-être échec top 10 des acheteurs dès
que j'avais faim c'est donc nulle et
voilà moralité facile victoire de
mariage gay du bas relief s'est
qualifiée s'est qualifié il jouera en
finale le vainqueur de great choc contre
kasparov qui aura lieu ce soir à 22h
donc si vous avez des questions à poser
sur le tchat
et bien vous pouvez nous les poser
maintenant on y répondra avec plaisir
en attendant nous allons bien vous
détailler le match à venir le prochain
match à venir qui aura lieu stéphane 22h
moyenne deux heures match qui s'annonce
explosif tkachuk a tenu tête à kasparov
de façon très brillante et on a vu qu'en
blitz il était extrêmement dangereux
c'est sûr c'est sûr ça va être un très
très beau match 19h55 en direct alors
que pour l'instant nous attendons
toujours vos éventuelles questions sur
le tchat
puisque nous sommes là pour y répondre
effectivement avec robert fontaine donc
champion de france
2000 chez les juniors stéphane laborde
donc une référence peut-être cinq et
demi sur 6 l'année dernière en nationale
2 donc perf à plus de 2400 je crois
white belleterre fois et c'est vrai
belle perf et moi même donc et loire
l'ange grand homme et un grand m donc
nous attendons vos éventuelles questions
alors que pour l'instant sur la scène et
bien il y a écrit tchouk et barrail f
qui se parlent et décidèrent aussi il ya
une réunion de joueurs alors que robert
va nous quitter et bien robert horry te
remercie et je vous rejoins évidemment à
22h ce soir pour le match
c'est très sympa alors nous commandent
des commentaires sur le match de
stéphane celui qu'on met une voix sur
celui là eh bien on peut dire que judith
a pas réussi dans la première partie et
son ouverture et se fait encore une fois
dominé elle a n'a pas réussi avec les
pièces blanches assure la nul qu'ils
auraient permis de lutter à armes égales
dans cette partie c'est vrai c'est vrai
donc ça c'est un premier commentaire bon
il faut dire que j'ai dites donc été
éliminé maintenant l euro elle ne
rejouera plus c'est sûr ça c'est vrai
mais c'est la dure loi du système à
élimination directe ce soir qui va être
éliminé kas port fondation qu'on ne sait
pas alors qu'est ce qu'on voit dans la
salle c'était panne est ce qu'on voit
des stars ou des
ou dvi p non là je n'en vois pas là tout
à fait on ne voit personne on ne voit
personne
donc on va vous laisser on va vous
laisser sur ce plan final très beaux
plans de la salle qui se vide avec les
deux commentateurs incrusté en plein
milieu donc on vous donne rendez vous ce
soir 21h55 et je vous rejoins tout de
suite en cabine pour le chat
merci de nous avoir suivis